in eSports as in life there exists a
fine line between genius and insanity
we've seen things that should work fail
miraculously these switches to the knife
it's all he has to work with they're all
it they tap it they want to bait him out
he's swinging and we've witnessed things
that shouldn't even be attempted
somehow yielding successful results
simple I swear if you do anything
ridiculous now I am going to but for all
of the galaxy brained goofballs who've
made their mark on competitive gaming
there is one who stands above the rest
one who's become so fixated on thinking
outside the box that every once in a
while it looks as if he's lost the
ability to think at all and they don't
know he's out there are they are they
gonna work no they think he's gone
[Applause]
Oh Jackie eternalenvy Mao is one of the
coin-flip iasts competitive gamers alive
and he's developed a reputation for
doing things that are so transparently
absurd that it genuinely isn't clear
whether their strokes of brilliance or
fits of madness and be pretty low can
they do this centuries down Ocoee
straight away with the snowball and
beasts gonna get caught out by the first
stun it does half the time that's
available if he needs it in fact he's
just turn it without punching it to s4
now he'll go for the laps looks towards
s4 as Paul gets the Sun as how and be
incredibly low running himself back
through the treeline
Oh Judah hunting they've got the switch
of the pony mask for quick with the face
you have to spot fully incredibly loners
Paul's gonna fall there you're gonna get
the kill Derek's now trying to get out
of there but he may fall as well he does
it's a double kill for NV now Luna wants
five fly trauma the TV by universe is
there with the burrowstrike fanatic
Helene up over the years Envy
single-minded commitment to this
unreliable 50/50 play style has taken on
a life of its own oftentimes to the
detriment of his own career so how is it
that NV became both the smartest and
dumbest player DotA's ever seen and why
is it that even though it hurts to watch
his inconsistency is actually kind of
inspiring I think big picture wisely
[Music]
okay so if you're into eSports and you
haven't heard of eternal NV brah
you're missing it on the outside he
might appear to have the enthusiasm of
drying paint but when it comes to dota
you will have a hard time finding a more
passionate competitor under the cheese
of the cheese's the cheese
the aegis and she's each of the cheese
with our room we do not room for rung
KGB top furry on KTP top your stick your
stick your stick
we need to act cool slam when the
gyrocopter drop your stick drop your
stick right now right now right now
right now right now go further on KGB
top furry on KUTV top what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you doing you [ __ ] idiot
we're way too [ __ ] slow just trust me
I'm [ __ ] better than all of you on
top of being known as an authoritarian
leader with a short fuse ee has built up
a reputation over the years for dishing
out surprise kicks and for being one of
the filthiest weebs eSports has ever
seen and ee sama as his fans have
affectionately named him has pretty much
risen to become the closest thing dota
has to a cult leader just do it but he
didn't stumble into this status because
he ditched university to successfully
pursue a pro gaming career or because he
played a pivotal role in putting any
dota on the map no Envy is both
celebrated and ridiculed for being one
of the xavius and most unorthodox Theory
crafters his game has ever seen unlike
most strategists Envy's philosophy
wasn't to win by out playing or out
thinking his opponents his objective
instead was to confuse them you want to
be getting those wards out making sure
that there's no wards blocking all your
camps if you're looking to pull if
you're looking to do anything else
you've got to keep your eyes open for
that one and wow admiralbulldog giving a
freebie and here we go uh-huh game is on
day is lame there's a small blood patch
were admirable in the trap and it is
it's actually trapped because they came
to check for it
then the Sun bigger than I've known
they're gonna bring it down
oh boy James now will the beam is this
we may pull something out of the bag 10
feet is gonna go down as well Oh
tidehunter water stop what a strategy
coming out for material Envy so we're
exactly to envy get his penchant for
preposterous play well like any fine
cheese it was aged in the good old
cellars of starcraft 2 me going to toss
away less you again by 2014 Envy had
found a home alongside other fresh-faced
innovators on cloud 9 and he was
beginning to cement himself as a
figurehead of the new school approach
taking competitive dota by storm c9
quickly running out of options
although Envy here you go into the back
door is really gets the mid lane of
barracks and might be able to mega LGD
this could turn into it a good
old-fashioned face race and B go
straight for the tier 4 berserkers call
misery goes down bone 7 it'll be a die
back for him not many reinforcements
left for cloud 9 to bed he gets one of
the tier 4 towers one more still
remaining but LGD they've got the
numbers advantage they get a tier 4
Tower now as well Envy she just got a
tussle from the enemy shop he'll go into
the tier 4 as well it's gonna be really
close to a winter scene I trying to
defend his best they can father he's
bought bags he's doing what damage he
can radiant they still have to question
that Saskia deadness trash but they
can't focus and throw themselves since
then the view of the heroes Botha doing
a lot of damage this is gonna be damn
close so much on the line here
internal and we might be able to do it
to get his teammate place lgt they just
want the throw but they can't its ND oh
my god winter you called it and envy did
it and we could just see things others
couldn't he could find opportunities
where others didn't even think to look
are they gonna win this game
amber has buyback but the other two
heroes are dead for their duration and
VIII shifting over he wants to buy
something to help him go for Owen he
sees some gems there's no cheese
[Applause]
taking the tier 4 Tower
you see DotA's chaotic complexity is
what makes it such an infamously
daunting eSport it's also what
distinguishes it from the fisher-price
knockoff that is League of Legends get
[ __ ] anyway envy and dota were a match
made in heaven here you had a try-hard
who was addicted to winning in the most
batshit dramatic ways imaginable and an
esport capable of surprising even its
most ardent followers he got absolutely
shredded and be they'll try their best
at all anything I've seen a big amount
of void in my life
needless to say it didn't take long for
envy to start doubling down on this
unpredictable all-or-nothing play style
that point go forward a beautiful loss
you just go for it oh yeah you have to
make this game way more chaotic than
this and make into a game where no one
else tends to it anymore because if both
teams understand daughter right now that
both teams understand them eg I lost the
game the problem is that sometimes he
take his philosophy a little too far
there are no stunts so it's gonna be a
right-click for us oh my god come on
dude you just want to stabilize the lane
so shallow Finn is still gonna win the
mid matchup if he loses he risks losing
bottom this could be like a big impact
on the game I wouldn't do it I hope you
wouldn't do it
[Laughter]
now to be fair there were a variety of
reasons as to why Envy's nutty antics
didn't always pan out sometimes it
simply felt as if he'd been dealt a bad
hand they're doing it they've already
got the trees they've already smoked up
they're going for a level and Roshan but
I believe Goomba they know to check it
they're not stupid
they're gonna check thanks right guys
maybe guys you're gonna go check the
Rosh pit right it's an Ursa with fury on
trees like ladies that combo yeah okay
they're gonna reveal it now the Fischer
comes in stunts up everybody just to
make sure that near is able to survive
now small slight if this goes down as
well
good shackleshot but in the end Goomba
don't really have the direct damage
required to be able to kill anybody just
yet they're actually gonna go right back
into the pit c9 they're fully committing
to this one this is crazy
oh they actually stopped the last bit of
clarity here for Earthshaker he's
playing pretty ballsy with his position
right now if c9 were just to run at him
there's a good chance he would fall he's
got no real escape now another Fischer
goes down trying to finish up both seven
they get first blood and team and they
go right back to try and do Roche on
Luna Falls as well due to a great
shackleshot from aria unbelievable
points cloud nine doing here and other
times it felt as if he brought it onto
himself like he'd done something so
absurd that it left you questioning
everything
oh and you might get the courier here is
there anything on it now so just simply
trying to be annoying and gotta kind of
we no one saw that
bringing the pusseh out of the game link
OMB is going in everything
oh goodness
Jackie mouth he does it again eventually
envies never-ending journey to one-up
both himself and his opponents started
doing more harm than good he'd become so
focused on executing some grand master
plan that he'd completely lose sight of
the big picture they want to have that
buyback first boot so chavos bought he
made his go for the trade here he's
keeping in the bottom light they're
going for a pastries Ivan has survived
the only side for now is switch them to
courier who goes set this up secretive
bushy top that they're also pushing
bottom
what's the Mersey to see that go through
through they put it back off they don't
even go in for the rats right now where
are the cheap peas father does not have
a teepee and be also I don't think as a
teepee no one has CPS or Milius getting
something going for the throne oh no
it's a catastrophe
the cloud night he comes says for as
well they just running back there
running for dear life they've got to
protect the base I'm chasing that pups
the ultimate there's no clip available
he dies in the mountain when he's got
ages he can't even fight back and TPR
they're just gonna get the throne over
this holy [ __ ] cloud might have lost
Game two I can't believe it what just
happened but here's the really crazy
thing you see every once in a while
envies reliance on the ridiculous
instead of the rudimentary would create
magic and you'd be left thinking what in
the hell did I just watch
c9 have not scouted this at all they're
in a helluva trouble if I don't go back
right now
that's first blood so did
unless yes bottle charges coming in
that's up the door all right
first bud goes to FC Mellie once a
second it's Big Daddy who's taking heavy
heavy hits gets the jewel up but the
hill comes up from the flame gun and
bone seven and eternal Envy both blow
nice totem from PPD catches out too and
with fierce rotation it looks like c9
gonna get overrun top lane they've lost
three for one then any why okay and B
says I'll take the extra bet Oh No Wow
are you gonna blink anything
here comes back up its way and the
fissure misses oh my gosh and fat has
come back as well PPD is trap wow what a
stir strikes godlike play by Envy that
was really really good thus a community
meme was born one built around the idea
that you never knew how one of Envy's
plays was going to turn out that in
nearly every instance of his play there
was a 50% chance that envy to go full
Jack Elam ow
doesn't matter let's go fight them
doesn't matter so under go oh my god
I'm so good at dota I'm bad at same time
is amazing or bolstered by the power of
God and anime rise and show no mercy
[Applause]
[Applause]
change but the drag until they'll kill
MV they come again they've gotta get
themselves the hell out of there there's
no more reminisce for seconds but MV
managing to take the rocha the community
even made a subreddit in honor of the
fifty-fifty phenomenon but unfortunately
a lot of that appreciation wasn't
especially positive it's no secret that
eSports isn't always friendly that even
the most talented players are regularly
roasted for failing to live up to the
unrealistic expectations of their fans
so if you're a superstar who's as prone
to blunders as Envy while let's just say
it can be doubly difficult the problem
of course is that over time and V's play
style just became too crazy
he went from winning a major to bouncing
around from roster to roster and bombing
out of Ti year after year after year
it's safe to say that at some point fans
competitors and community figures
started viewing him differently he was
starting to be seen less as an asset and
more as a liability who is who was sold
on a ton an MV like who would want a
tunnel MV in that team you know rise or
fall it's very entertaining to watch him
but I just say I believe on a team you
want these people that just seem
stable but while a lot of people are
quick to ridicule Envy's idiosyncratic
play the fact that he isn't afraid to
take those kinds of risks in the first
place actually says a lot about who he
is as both a player and a person because
whatever else can be said about envy one
thing can't be denied
he truly couldn't care less what other
people think in a world as hostile and
immature as eSports where everyone's
chasing clout or being scrutinized envy
stands out he's one of those few figure
heads who in spite of all his faults has
the courage to just be himself and that
in itself is pretty inspiring pretty
much do whatever it takes to win as long
as it's not cheating or or anything that
breaks my pencil I would generally do it
that's all I am I don't really concern
myself
drop your stick drop your stick fear on
consumer top fear on connectivity top
figure I came to pick up the fudge
can you please miles can you please do
the goose meme for me please
[ __ ] please dude can you please just
do that just please my head on the air
horn and just oh oh that's like a
Shakespearean [ __ ] like lament it's
so beautiful